joey diaz you know used to
pace like a caged animal and i told him
he used to wear
suit three-piece suit but i told him i
said hey man
you're scaring people he's so big and
his movement was because he was also
[ __ ]
probably maple yeah no dude 240. oh wow
when i met him he was 240 coked up and
but he was
his movements were so
fast and furious and he was pacing the
stage and he was doing this with his
hand
i was like hey man you know what he just
posted
he and rogan just posted a video i mean
a picture of him
and that is even 10 pound maybe not 10.
50 pounds heavier than when i met him he
was a
man coco was a there it is my brother
took that head shot look at this dude
so he's probably 2 80 there so i met him
probably
40 pounds lighter i feel like i'm slowly
morphing into jokes can you not look
similar yeah man put a bandana on that
dude you're not too funny
[Applause]
a sexy [ __ ] man what can only
hope
i used to love it i go what are you
doing tonight he was like i'm slinging
dick and giving up bubble gum
that's a great picture yeah man we took
it like cleaning out the office
that's right that's in back of el
compadre how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son